hey guys what's up this is going to be
my Snoke episode 8 video just talking
about the backstory that they've
explained so far there are a lot of
great theories about Snoke
there's the mace windu theory I'll do
videos for that stuff too
but that's a little crazier this is
based on the information that's actually
canon that they've revealed us there is
a new round of the Star Wars giveaway
for IMAX tickets all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video if you're new to the
channel be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts I usually make important
announcements at the end of videos most
of what we know about snoke's backstory
comes through other characters
backstories the aftermath tie-in book
series for episode 7
there were a couple novels that was
aftermath aftermath life-debt that sort
of explained what was going on with the
first order the lead-in to episode 7 so
a lot of people ask why wasn't he around
during the original trilogy why didn't
they write him in the way they're
filling in gaps in the Canon like they
did during rogue one with the big
weakness in the Death Star they're
sewing up a lot of the logic they
haven't said how old he is but they did
say that he's a humanoid alien he's not
a former human he used to be handsome
but was twisted by the dark side of the
force he has that giant scar running
down his forehead clearly a battle he
has sort of like a burn mark that causes
him to speak in a funny way so you know
that through the practice of the dark
side of the force he got into battles
was scarred but survived in is now the
de-facto leader for the opposition to
the Jedi so we still have Jedi because
Luke Skywalker still exists there was
the New Jedi Order he was part of
another group of dark side force users
that were not associated with the Sith
that rose up after the fall of the
Emperor we knew Princess Leia was aware
of him during the rise of the New
Republic knew he was a dark side force
user knew that her son Ben was
susceptible to that chose not to warn
Han Solo about him because she felt it
was her duty to protect her son because
she was force sensitive she wanted him
with Luke there were a lot of those
moments during the force awakens where
you get the sense that she made a lot of
errors that led to her and Han Solo
splitting up people like how come there
Devore
how come they're not together anymore
but they really brushed over a lot of
those details in Episode seven but it's
all there in the expanded material well
I saw her son he was here every time you
look at me you're reminded of him you
think I want to forget him I want him
back he's nothing more we could have
done it's too much treasure that's why I
wanted to be trained with Luke I just
never ship sent him away that's when I
lost him that's where I lost you
[Music]
we both had to deal with it in our own
way I went back to the only thing I was
a very good thought we lost our son
forever no it was Snoke she seduced our
son to the dark side but we can still
save him me the other really interesting
detail is that Leia and everyone else
hid the identity of Anakin Skywalker
Darth Vader from Ben growing up they
didn't let him know that his grandfather
was Darth Vader he knew he was a
Skywalker but for some reason they were
able to shroud the truth from him Leia's
opposition inside the New Republic
she had political enemies used that
information against her so she was
forced to tell him he felt abandoned
that lied to that's when Snoke was able
to turn him to the dark side of the
force but he was also able to take
control of the first order as it
continued to rise they explained through
Leia's story and all these aftermath
books in the lead up to episode 7 that
she saw the threat of the remnants of
the empire but the New Republic wasn't
taking it seriously they didn't take the
first order seriously so that's why she
left and formed the resistance to try
and fight them independently in for a
brief period the New Republic would help
them out one of the biggest reasons why
the first order targeted those worlds
that were populated by the New Republic
was to cut off all the support and
resources they were giving to the
resistance so based on the hierarchy a
lot of people also think that Snoke is
somebody that we've seen in the expanded
material but he hasn't become Snoke or
taken that name we know that he's an
alien humanoid but we don't know what
his name was before it was Snoke we
don't know if he has another name there
was an imperial general character in the
life-debt book that a lot of people
think secretly was Snoke called Gaius
Rex
he's a fleet admiral with the first
order or with the remnants of the Empire
who forms the shadow Council and becomes
a very powerful figure so a lot of
people feel like he might turn out to be
Snoke he has this mysterious name called
the
operator but the whole reason for that
is it is just really hard for somebody
who has no association with the Empire
or the first order to roll in and
completely take control of everything
we know that Snoke formed a new darkside
ordered just like the church as a force
was formed there's a mysterious
character named Tasha who's a darkside
historian that pops up during the
aftermath series so just like lor San
Tekka during the force awakens was this
figure who served the force you have
people who serve the dark side of the
force that we just haven't seen a lot of
yet that we'll see during episode eight
so Snoke using these people and new
recruits to form the Knights of red has
this special new order of dark side
force users
he had an apprentice before Ben
Skywalker who's briefly mentioned you
don't know a lot about him but then he
became obsessed with the lineage of
Darth Vader thinking that he would be a
focal point in the force in the really
cool thing about this new darkside order
that we learned in it they call
themselves acolytes of the beyond the
beyond part means beyond the galaxy as
we know it so if you read the expanded
universe there are things that come from
outside the known universe there's the
Unknown Regions there are places of
space within the Star Wars universe that
just haven't been mapped very well so a
little Palpatine backstory he felt like
a lot of his power came from somewhere
beyond of the galaxy now he believed in
the force of the very broad way but it's
just teasing the idea that we're going
to be seeing things from outside the
galaxy as we know it but by all accounts
is powerful a dark side force user is
Snoke is he was just a normal person
that became twisted by the dark side of
the force physically but is very
different from Palpatine in his approach
to how the first order works like when
the Starkiller base blows up he doesn't
care he's just very calm during kylo Ren
to me it's time to finish his training
the fuel cells are up to
the collapse of the planet has begun
he's the base at once and come to me
with kylo Ren time training the Emperor
was very proud of both Death Star's he's
really big on washing himself of emotion
which is kind of controversial because
the dark side is all about embracing
that emotion but a lot of people inside
the first order as well as Snoke felt
like the Empire was just as responsible
for its downfall as the rebels were
there's this really cool quote from
Snoke to kylo Ren as they're talking to
each other about the downfall of the
Empire and his grandfather Darth Vader
he says it was neither poor strategy nor
arrogance that brought down the Empire
you know - well what did in kylo Ren
nods and says sentiment Snoke replies
yes had lord Vader not succumbed to
emotion at the crucial moment had the
father killed the son the Empire would
have prevailed and there would be no
threat of Skywalker's return today so
you learned that Snoke is very worried
about Luke Skywalker coming back
probably turning kylo Ren back to the
light side of the force but he also
teaches kylo Ren that emotion in
sentiment are very bad things that's why
he showed so much concern when kylo Ren
was trying to track down the Millennium
Falcon because he will be facing his
father that would be an extremely
sentimental moment so you can see that
his politics as well as his approach to
the dark side of the force is very
different from the Emperor's so that's
the whole idea he's still meant to be a
very ambiguous character just so they
can continue to explore that in the new
movies but when they say that Snoke is a
brand new character Andy Serkis said
this is a character you haven't seen
before it's just a new character that
they're weaving into the Canon they
haven't explained exactly how old he is
but he has parity with the Emperor a lot
of people felt like going into Episode 7
there were rumors that he would be this
ancient person on the edges of the force
when it was announced that Andy Serkis
would be doing motion capture a lot of
people felt like he was going to be some
crazy hulking figure but the hologram
just makes him look that big 25 feet
tall in reality he's still very tall
more like parody with Darth Vader who
was over seven feet tall so very very
tall in his armor but not quite as tall
as Chewbacca
so hopefully that explains a little
about snoke's origins why he wasn't part
of the Emperor's Council why he's not a
character that we've seen before mostly
to keep him mysterious but they will
weave him in once they explained his
backstory someone from within the Empire
who had a lot of political clout was
able to build a following and seize
control of the first order in the chaos
that was the end of the Empire the
really cool detail I think though is the
idea that Princess Leia was aware of him
the whole time so he's not somebody to
just came out of nowhere so that's sort
of like a gap in the logic of the
franchise right now that they'll show up
once they explain it so he used to look
much more humanoid they refer to him as
being handsome so you could imagine him
looking just like any other person but
he wasn't a human like the Emperor from
Naboo
he was alien humanoid what I'll probably
do for one of my next Star Wars bonus
videos is talk about the new force order
that he's trying to create they call
them force warriors not Jedi knots it's
something completely new in between both
of those things
grey Jedi is probably the best
comparison that I could make but a lot
of people have said that grey Jedi
aren't canon anymore but I will do a
video on grey Jedi nonetheless just to
explain how there are certain force
users they practice ideas that are
somewhere between the dark side and the
light side of the force like they try to
harness everything in a slightly
different context to what the Jedi Order
taught there's a whole lot of the
mythology that we have to talk about
there's going to be really exciting this
year but those slowly teased details out
is we get new trailers there's rumors
that will get teasers before celebration
but I think the first episode eight real
trailer will drop at Star Wars
Celebration this year congratulations to
the new Star Wars giveaway winner a
train game please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video I'll
just announce the winner the next time I
post a Star Wars video what do you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn more about Episode eight and
you can click here to learn more about
Luke Skywalker thank you so much for
watching everybody cuz I thought I'll
see you in the next video Mickey Minnie
Mickey
me maybe the game
[Music]